[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight
last night on this show we told you
about what may be the single
most extreme and disruptive piece of
legislation ever to gain widespread
support in the congress in the history
of this country
it's called the new way forward act it's
before congress right now and has been
for almost two months
and yet so far it has been essentially
ignored by the country's major media
outlets which are either
too embarrassed of it or too ignorant to
cover it
that's a disservice to you because it's
really impossible to describe
just how radical this bill is if passed
it would remake our immigration system
for the express
purpose of helping foreign-born
criminals live here
the bill would allow people who've
committed serious felonies in other
countries
to move to the united states legally it
would make it nearly impossible for
federal immigration officials
to detain immigrants no matter how
potentially dangerous they are
and perhaps most infuriatingly and
remarkably
it would require taxpayers to transport
deported criminals
back into the united states in other
words you break our laws
you hurt our people we'll send you a
plane ticket we'll pay for you
to come back it's utter and total
insanity
and yet it's very popular in the
democratic party
so far this bill has 44 democratic
co-sponsors
on the screen is a list of some of their
names some of these people you've heard
of before
alexandria ocasio-cortez ilhan omar
rashida talib
they're celebrities but some are obscure
earl blumenau for example has
represented oregon for decades
before this he's maybe been best known
for running the
congressional bicycle caucus and yet
all of a sudden out of nowhere
blumenauer has decided to wreck the
country
now we'd like to talk to earl blumenauer
on this show
we'd like to hear why he supports this
bill
we'd like to talk to any of the people
who've co-sponsored it
we reached out to many of them today to
come on and defend their views
but not one of them agreed to come why
because they're cowards
and yet we think you ought to know what
they're doing here's the bill's primary
sponsor jesus garcia of illinois
after introducing the bill garcia said
this
this is not a radical project we are
simply asking for a fair shot
and the opportunity for immigrants to
stay in the country
they call home a new way forward does
just that
it would end mandatory immigration
detention
and the automatic pipeline to
deportation
through the criminal justice system it
would end
deportation for people who have had
contact
with the criminal legal system it would
end the practices of
local police engaging in immigration
enforcement
and the increased ever policing of
communities
of color it would decriminalize
immigration
this is not a radical project of course
the opposite is true the bill is
completely radical it would transform
america into a place you don't recognize
many of the sponsors of this bill come
from the fringes of the democratic party
as you would expect
but not all of them do consider
congressman andy levin
levin represents the suburbs north of
detroit
levin's district leans blue but it's
still essentially bipartisan voters
there went for hillary clinton for
example by just eight points
so there's no chance a majority of andy
levin's voters want to send plane
tickets to armed robbers in guatemala so
they can move next door
and in fact nobody wants that no matter
what they claim on twitter
yet levin is trying to do that right now
and that's what's scary about this bill
it's happening
in the dark no one's talking about it
those who are dismiss it as unlikely
it'll never happen
that's a mistake things change fast in
modern america on issue after issue from
ending the second amendment to banning
biological gender
to the open and aggressive racism of
identity politics
yesterday's extremism has become today's
democratic party platform
that's how it works now four years ago
when bernie sanders mounted his first
campaign for president
vox.com pressed him on why he didn't
back open borders for the world
sanders responded this way quote no
that's a koch brothers proposal which
says essentially
there is no united states it would make
everybody in america
poor end quote of course sanders was
entirely right
and for that crime he was savaged by vox
and all the other angry children in
woken
resisting the abolition of the united
states was in their view needless to say
proof that sanders was a hardened bigot
a racist four years later
sanders has become obedient his new
platform contains all the usual open
borders rhetoric
ending all deportations abolishing ice
giving a blanket amnesty to all illegal
aliens in the country
now new hampshire voter recently asked
sanders why his views had changed so
radically
the man who once called lacks
immigration enforcement a koch brothers
conspiracy
just four years ago suddenly sounded
very much like a koch brother himself
we have 11 million undocumented here
many of those workers by the way are
being
exploited right now you know trump wants
to throw everybody out of the country if
he threw out
people out of the country the price of
food in this country would skyrocket who
do you think is picking the crops and
planting
all over this country who's picking the
crops
actually machines are picking most of
the crops in this country now and
planting them
too bernie is almost 80 years old and
apparently nobody told him that
but either way it is still shocking to
hear that explanation from a
self-described socialist
so yes workers are being exploited but
think about what
avocados would cost if citizens had to
pick them
it's nauseating sanders isn't stupid
he has to know his party's turning
immigration hurts workers and the
country
but he desperately wants to be president
of the united states
so he goes along with it you're seeing
quite a bit of this
by the way joe biden who's supposedly
the most moderate man in politics old
uncle joe
now is pushing for
illegal aliens to get off on duis watch
you only arrest for the purpose of
dealing with
a felony that's committed and i don't
count drunk driving as a felony
the confused ravings of a fading old man
no
hardly they all think that way now if
democrats win the 2020 election
some version of the new way forward act
will likely become law
once again keep this in mind things move
fast in this country so be ready